1984 it's a good year
[Music]
Wonder Woman news so the sequel to a
Wonder Woman now officially titled
Wonder Woman 1984 has begun shooting and
we have the first publicity stills to
show it um so I'm gonna talk about them
normally I would talk about like oh this
thing finally started shooting here's
our first image is like it's not the
kind of thing that I like to devote a
whole video to except that I really
liked Wonder Woman and I'm really
excited for this second film so let's
start with the title I mean obviously
it's incredibly descriptive 1984 it's
the year the things gonna be set in I
actually really like this as a naming
convention because I I love you know I I
accept that just sticking a number at
the end of things
isn't really how we deal with sequels
anymore we tend to give them you know
alternate names you know completely
different names all together you know
you had Batman Begins Dark Knight Dark
Knight Rises or you know the way the
Fast and Furious does their weird sort
of thing and I'm not sure something like
that would work for Wonder Woman unless
you just wanted to call it like Diana
Prince
but the alternative and the more and the
other thing is like to do the colon and
then the subtitle and I honestly I
really don't like that so for knowing
that this is a film that's gonna be
filling in you know basically some of
the time between when we last saw her
well not when we saw her origin um
satnaam back in World War 1 and when she
showed up in Batman V Superman this so I
think honestly a really cool way to make
it immediately clear like they don't
even have to worry about like when a
first trailer comes out or whatever
people are going like wait when is this
it's the title the title tells you when
it's set and I actually think it's it's
it just kind of rolls off the tongue
well Wonder Woman 1984 and also calling
it something like this actually would
enable them if they wanted with further
sequels to not even have to set it after
1984 you could set it earlier we can
get Wonderwoman 1966 down the line and
it'd be fine
whereas if this was called you know
Wonder Woman - you know yeah we would be
weird if Wonder Woman 3 was set before
that and if we had just done the
subtitles of colons I just it probably
just would've been called something
stupid so title I like as for the images
there is one that I just really like and
one that makes me nervous
so the one that I like is this one this
shot I just like the color the mood
i-i'll I love the palette it pops it's
vibrant which is what I want Wonder
Woman was of course one of the more
colorful DC films but they did still
kind of do the dis a ated thing during
the World War one section which
somatically fit you know man's world was
dark and gray and ugly compared to the
mascara so that all fit that matched
fine but it's nice to sort of see us now
completely leave that D saturated
palette behind so I'm happy with that
and you know it's just kind of a nifty
image there's just something about her
looking at these older style TVs I don't
know it's just cool but then there's
also this image now this one makes me
very very very very very nervous and I'm
just gonna put this back out I'm just
gonna put this out there very bluntly I
really need this to be a dream sequence
or a vision or the villain somehow
messing with her I need this to not be
Steve Trevor coming back from the dead I
need it to not be that you know I look
it's based off comic books I can accept
the fact that it is possible to bring
him back that there is some way to do
that I'm not saying there's no way to
bring him back it breaks my immersion
suspect to disbelieve it it doesn't I
could buy that he could come back I
really don't want them to do it though
it's not because I didn't like Chris
Pine the part I thought it was really
good the part I thought he had good
chemistry with gal gadot I
to them together but he had such a good
well executed death his the the point at
which he makes the decision to do this
you know the the what he says to Diana
when he leaves the sadness of her being
unable you know to hear him when he says
it and then when he's up in that plane
and he you know he's getting it high
enough in these he's you know he's
taking control of the plane and he sort
of has a moment he's like I did it and
then it sort of comes across his face
what that means and he doesn't just
immediately do the heroic thing and blow
the plane up he pauses like that pause
is everything to me and that it's that
pause that makes him a hero because it
you know it's not just the adrenaline of
got to do this you know to save the
world and yeah pushing him along he he
pauses this is a measured decision it
makes it more tragic it makes it more
powerful it makes it a great death and
while I can accept that it is possible
for basically any character in a
superhero movie to be able to be brought
back from the dead when it is such a
perfectly done death as that I don't
want to see it undone because it
retroactively Lee makes that moment
which is a great moment from the
previous film empty it robs it of
meaning it's it's part of the reason
it's there are many reasons but it's
part of the reason I can't stand the
Doctor Who episode hell-bent because it
undoes a incredibly excellently done
death of a character from two episodes
previous I hate that so it is really
important to me that this is not
actually Steve Trevor back from the dead
appearing now in 1984 the fact that he's
just kind of standing there and what
looks at least to my eye like a school
or something like that's not a place he
belongs and and I read that as a bit of
a you know a just strange look on him
I am at this point for my own comfort
and sanity choosing to believe that this
is some sort of like I said dream
sequence vision you know he's he's you
know maybe even reaching out from from
the Greek underworld like from Hades
like fine I'll buy that but just not
back alive I please please don't do that
and that's about all that I have to say
there's not too much else to go there's
no I think the next thing that I'm gonna
be really curious to see is when we're
gonna get our first look at Kristen Wiig
as cheetah who's the villain now I like
cheetah has a villain quite a bit
actually I also don't like Kristen Wiig
I can't and I can't really quantify that
I can't be like because X it's she's one
of those actors who I just don't like
her there's something about her that
rubs me the wrong way there's I've got a
few like that there's her there's Sam
Rockwell and and I would never say these
people aren't good at what they do but
for whatever reason there's something
about them that seems to be inherent
with them because they I feel it every
single time I see them on screen that
like I don't want to be watching you
when I get that offer so I am both
curious and nervous to see what she is
gonna look like but you know and that's
sort of the next major development that
I'll be interested in but yeah initial
title and these first images for Wonder
Woman 1984 have you seen them what do
you think about them whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do such as like and
subscribe to support me on patreon
follow me on Twitter attack that out
that I thought I'll links for all that
stuff is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]